extremely excited about exploring on
this channel are different approaches to
quantum gravity and you said in an
offhand statement is that i think we
need a different understanding of time
in order to make a breakthrough in
quantum gravity please explain that
yes yes
yeah so indeed so quantum gravity that's
of course a huge challenge and uh
very little progress in the in the last
uh decades
uh okay maybe i'm going to annoy a few
of my colleagues but i don't think we
have made any breakthrough i think
that's a fair statement to be fair
professor almost everyone has a
variation of that statement that we need
a new understanding of x in order to
make progress in quantum gravity whether
we need a new understanding of space we
need a new understanding of strings we
need a new understanding of holographic
so why time
okay okay good so why time
so time has plays a completely different
role in relativity so gravity and in
quantum mechanics
you know in relativity i mean that the
usual picture is this block universe
where everything is kind of frozen
since ever forever and there is no no
present
you have to add it by hand
and even einstein was a bit concerned
with the lack of the present
in quantum mechanics at least the
standard view is this indeterminacy on
the beam splitter with the two detectors
for instance
and so there is clearly a process going
on nowadays
before the photon hits the detector and
gets localized in one or the other
detector
and there is a time after it has
triggered one and only one of the
detectors so there is clearly a passage
of time there
and now we have this uh
these two uh
basic theories
which
they fundamentally disagree about what
time is
and then how do you want you know to
develop a
dynamical theory of quantum gravity
if we don't even agree on what time is
and whether this is you know whether the
passage of time is a real phenomenon us
in standard
quantum mechanics
or is it
just the kind of illusion us in the
block universe presented by relativity
so i think this is really a
fundamental issue and we need to be able
to
um
yeah to if we want to do quantum gravity
we need to have one concept that is
going to unify that i know i wouldn't
say that i have solved the problem i
mean certainly not
but i
my hope is that by you know introducing
indetermination also in classical
pre-relativity mechanics so newtonian
mechanics but i have already introduced
uh indeterminacy there so somehow i have
brought these classical mechanics and
quantum mechanics closer together
i have also one paper on the
indeterminacy is relative so going one
more step in the direction of relativity
but okay this is maybe it's uh
i don't think we should enter that kind
of debate anyway it is still under
development but the goal is indeed to
bring also indetermination to relativity